recently there was a conversation uh
because um me and priests both been part
of the dance community for some time
yeah and uh i'd heard a story that made
me chuckle a little bit but it's kind of
[ __ ] up but it's something i was kind
of used to back in l.a
back in l.a
i know what you're going to say yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] up back in l.a
choreographer uh actually i don't think
you know what i was gonna say a
choreographer got out it because um
basically he was running casting calls
for tours for certain people and
basically was requesting that men send
nudes or solicit sexual things from them
in order to get on with the job and you
know some people it made a little bit of
but not that much noise
and
i laughed a little bit because
a lot of people were shocked like oh my
god this is that i'm like you know that
your favorite dancer probably had to do
a little such thing to be able to get on
tour the same way that your favorite
actress had to do something something
yeah the only difference is when it
comes to the dancing this stuff nobody
shines a light on it because it's not
that big of a deal let me tell you this
the metoo stuff has not made its rounds
to the danes community much and it
certainly hasn't made this round to the
gay community very much yeah we're gonna
talk about it oh because having been an
artist for a long time having lived in
los angeles been around a lot of these
circles let me tell you you
[ __ ] are [ __ ] up okay
straight guys toxic gay dudes openly
toxic
okay it's acceptable hey don't matter if
you're straight or gay gay dudes will
come on to you the thing that remember
how like straight dudes will try to turn
a lesbian that's exactly what i want
yeah the their fantasy of a straight guy
two girls fantasy of a great dude
turning a straight guy
i have friends who would make it to
final rounds of auditions to go on tour
with a major artist take your brain jars
justin bieber whoever it might be it
doesn't matter okay final round and
getting an opportunity like that as a
dancer big deal so they make it to the
final round
and they're like we'll call you back
they all of a sudden start getting texts
yeah send me some pictures of yourself
no clothes on what the [ __ ] is this for
no clothes on it not even underwear it's
like what
of course the homie rejects it says i'm
not doing that like never
doesn't get on tour guess who gets on
tour a little bit more of a sus dude i
wonder what he had to do and it's very
buddy buddy all the choreographers know
each other they're all on close terms
yeah a lot of them know what the others
are doing
so even they're not part of it they know
about it
this is not like the biggest secret and
don't get me wrong there's straight guys
who are soliciting things from some
women as well i have no doubt
but it's like that the whole thing is
sus superstar sus listen
i don't see gay dudes
just grab people's junks grabs ass
whatever they wanted everybody just
laughs and giggles nobody even thought
that [ __ ] was weird very comfortable
hell i'll talk about two are forget tour
do you want to be on the youtube videos
when we do the choreography in class
i haven't seen that too you're not even
getting paid he was getting a little bit
of clout in the comment section
yes
it is that insidious you know terry
crews came out with the story talking
about how he was touched at a party he
froze up he's an actor doing big name
movies made lots of money and he's big
too and he didn't say no [ __ ] and i
imagine dancers barely making six
figures if they're lucky super lucky how
cocky in your game do you have to be to
come up to terry crews
and just grab his wrong how confident
about what you do and be like i don't
give a [ __ ] what you gonna do do you
remember the guy who did it
who
that's my whole point
we don't even know nor has he probably
been reprimanded right
and probably still out there yeah and so
it's even worse for dancers and i'll
tell you why i'll tell you why like in
this art scenes there's not much money
to be made so people have these dreams
of being a dancer there's no health
insurance you're putting your body on
the line you're trying for something big
right you put it on the dreams and you
come to find out the gateway between you
and what you want for your dreams
is a little hanky-panky under the
blanket
so you're desperate broke lily in los
angeles which is an untenable city and
very expensive or maybe it's new york
[ __ ] what do i know you need to make
money
a lot of straight dudes end up doing
some weird session
just to get their careers off the ground
and i remember the first time it dawned
on me how weird this [ __ ] was
i was i was having a practice session
underneath an apartment building they
had a little studio in the basement so
the person that lived there uh would
like let me come through and then we
would go down with your practice i'll
never forget this this was like one of
the most trippy moments america's
remember america's best dance group
so i go down to the basement
i
uh do the practice we finish up we open
the door to leave and as we're leaving
one of the choreographers from america's
best dance was coming down
and
what was his name
i'm not going to say his name he's a
major choreographer he's already in jail
oh i don't know
remember the guy with the hat who's in
the first season of america's best dance
for the black guy no no shane sparks
shane
i see shane sparks coming down the
stairs i can't remember because it was
like nine years ago i can't remember it
was a little girl little boy
they're coming down the stairs to go
into the studio and he's saying goodbye
to the parent
now listen i just seen james parks on
america's best dance i didn't think
about it
literally a year later
this guy gets dinged
for being involved with kids
and it really hit me in that moment that
a lot of people that i interacted with
in that scene that i thought were normal
or anything but yo and as i spent more
time in it i had people try to say some
[ __ ] to me i'm like bro get the [ __ ] out
of here absolutely because i don't need
to be a disney i don't care right so
i'm sitting back thinking to myself like
damn it's that common but it is and as i
spent more time and had more
conversation with people i find out oh
this person you wanna know how they got
on well they had to do this i'm like god
damn
and so as much as we glorify the whole
idea of being an artist and making it on
your own other stuff just know a lot of
these industries are really [ __ ] fit
absolutely they're absolutely disgusting
half those people in hollywood who you
admire so much a lot of them had to suck
some nasty dick i mean once the
weinstein stuff came out people came to
find out a lot of people had to suck
some nasty dick
but he's not the only one and it's
happening on smaller scales in areas
that nobody gives a [ __ ] about because a
either the victims are dudes or b it's
such a small scene nobody really cares
because they won't make waves but a lot
of these dudes if they're not dealing
kids they building men women they will
do whatever they want and i feel like
there's almost i don't know if this is
like in my head how i think about it i
feel like the drive to want to make it
there to have that much power is to be
insulated from any of the repercussions
for some of your dark desires yeah you
get me mm-hmm um a bunch of left lenders
man yeah and that's why i brought it up
when we were talking about the whole uh
ricky martin finally came out yeah oh it
didn't come out but it didn't come out
but i explained what happened is that
there's allegation that ricky martin was
involved with his nephew when he was
being abusive with his nephew then again
they're just allegations whatever but
just the fact that you're involved with
your nephew god damn ricky ricky
ricky
isn't he facing life in prison 50 years
that's not life
that's not like they did no nothing they
basically got they did some
investigations
they got they got some [ __ ] yes it's not
just a hearsay yes it's it's it's 50
years but why is that a big thing about
ricky martin specifically there's a lot
of dancers around there tomorrow a lot
of [ __ ] that dances some people
that i know but is it ricky straight
no he's not straight no ricky
he bangs he banks
he bangs he bangs
he about that life but a lot of time
everybody would say like at least a
public image that he would pursue was of
him being straight but a lot of people
would hear in the back scene that's not
exactly that's not his outlet and before
he came out we've been hearing about
stuff and i was like oh yeah we knew
when it finally came out that's the
thing when you work in the hard stuff
you hear some [ __ ] beforehand same thing
for comedy same thing for movies same
thing for anything i mean so it's just
yeah
a lot of such thing going on a lot of
the auditions whether it's for
the
dancers or the hearts performer in
circus weird
weird [ __ ] has a lot of background weird
[ __ ] trust us we're not gonna out
everything because you know we gotta
protect the name of the people that are
out there and then we got them out we
out them out repercussion right but
we've been told some [ __ ] up [ __ ] i'm
just getting told i've seen it i've seen
the messages i've seen
i've seen the suggestions i didn't see
the people touching in front of me yeah
yeah it's not like i have a degree of
removal i bore witness to you yeah yeah
yeah absolutely and then you say some
[ __ ] and
yeah you get cut off on some things but
whatever it is there is there is
definitely a problem out there yeah and
a lot of people being predatory whether
it's man or woman yep
yeah so we just want to let you guys
know maybe just take off the curtain a
little bit but yeah shane sparks went to
jail
yeah he's not the only one a few other
few of those big old heads
yeah they got a thing for young women
apparently new jersey and jersey and
yeah jersey city club music
you're next
you know some of y'all djs are weird